the Joe Rogan experience I know that
your life was hard mm-hmm but if you
have to live it over again what I mean
it made you who you are doesn't change
anything
yeah that's why I was gonna ask you but
it's a [ __ ] up thing to ask someone
when they tell you they molested but
your mom's boyfriend and that you know
you had a baby with this guy when you
were 14 and he's married another one and
by the time you're 16 you're pregnant
with a third yeah
no no whatever a great selling crack and
shot in the Tet no one would ever ask
you to live that life again but you you
wouldn't change it I don't know Joe I
mean it made me who I am but I always I
look at life like this I think I would
you know everybody couldn't have dealt
with the stuff that I dealt with it like
I dealt with it like some people commit
suicide comforting people always
depressed you know I kind of feel like I
was a chosen one god take you through
something so it can you know to make
other people see maybe I was put maybe I
took burden that everybody else was
going through in life and I I was a
chosen one then I bring it out and make
it funny so I'm here to make people let
let people know it's okay yeah it's okay
it's not about how you start it's about
how you finish right I don't dwell and
she don't have control over I can't
change the pace but let's laugh today
and I tell people every night on stage
when you can laugh about it you got
control of that's a powerful thing to be
able to look at your life like that and
just take ownership yeah you know like
my first kid's father he hates me he
[ __ ] hates me you know why cuz I'm
not that little girl rabbit anymore that
he had control of that he beat and he
you know I was a little girl searching
for love and in this whole situation I
learned to love myself Joe do you so
touch with them yeah talk to me because
of me al he's not in jail yeah good
Chapman I'm not a childless I remember
when I needed closure and um I was I was
out here in LA and uh I'm starting to
tell these stories about my life and I
just wanted him to apologize the only
shot me back of the head
[ __ ] beat me so I wanted him to
apologize and I was like why do you need
him to apologize I just wanna hear I
just want to take rabbit I'm sorry
so I called him up and I said it there
we started talk about it I said his name
oh are you going Joe I call him and
apologize and I said I said how can you
[ __ ] a 12 yo and you groaning you mayor
you know what he said
he said your mind and body wasn't well
and then she kicked me and my [ __ ]
chest like a horse and I boohoo and that
day Joe I decided I was no longer gonna
ask him to X for me to you know to ask
me to forgive him I decided to forgive
him I forgave my mama I forgave my mama
boyfriend and everybody else that
stepped on me and I said no longer I'm
ever gonna want to do come come come I
know I say from that day on I'm never
gonna ask y'all if I forget I'm never
gonna ask you again
I'm excited to forgive you and I that
day I forgave him my mom and her
boyfriend
and everybody else they ever violated me
cuz there was so many other people that
I don't still don't talk about but I
forgave them that's a very powerful
thing and I'm happy that's a very
powerful thing if you can forgive people
who've done terrible things to you and
you haven't done [ __ ] to them yeah the
people that wants them to apologize they
chase them down they can't get back that
you're eating yourself up you eating
yourself and I was eating myself because
I just wanted him to say I'm sorry
rabbit and he never said it but once he
told you that when you were 12 your mind
your body weren't young you gotta
realize you're talking to a [ __ ]
idiot Oh idiot and I called my husband
and I was crying he was like Pat why you
keep I said I just want him to ask me to
I just wanted to say he's sorry that's
all I want him to say and he's like Pat
why and I remember hanging up the phone
and I got on my knees and I rarely get
on my knees Joe and I got vertigo so I
don't get [ __ ] I'm talking about so I
just I mean I forgave him that day I
forgave him and my mama because of him
my mommy in her boyfriend John is three
other people that I hated the most
because she didn't protect me
when we once tried to tell her that her
boyfriend was doing that to us you know
he wasn't listening she wouldn't listen
because this man was providing it was
the only time in my life that we didn't
get evicted because he was touching me
and my son he was always saying well if
you tell your mama y'all gonna get put
out y'all ain't gonna have no food so we
always thought we was helping we always
thought he was helping so you know but I
forgave him I mean you know they was day
was already dead but he's still alive
he's still my kids father's still alive
and you want to know something crazy and
I never told anybody this so people I
was like why you don't go to your mama
gravesite you know a lot of people like
I don't like [ __ ] with the dead I
figured they want a rest leave him the
[ __ ] alone they don't wanna hear about
this lovely this lively [ __ ] I don't go
to her grave y'all because that
[ __ ] put his self next to her he
buried himself next to my mama so I said
[ __ ] both of you I'm not going up there
he's laying right next to last time I
was there before he died I was there
cleaning off some ants on top of gray
and you know I'm young I'm probably she
died when I was 16 I was 16 17 I go out
there what a gas can't pull it on top
and light it on fire to get the oh my
god I haven't been back Joe I don't need
to go back I won't go back he's next to
us so he wanted that control so he got
it
[ __ ] I'm never going back it's
[Laughter]